two types of living robots
from two universes how would they
compare
well in this video we are going to
compare them and discuss about mecha
godzilla and the transformers
and while we're at it we are also going
to ask the question
what if mechagodzilla was in the
transformers universe
more specifically the most diverse mecca
in the michael bay transformers
franchise
one is a gigantic mecca made to combat
and look like the king of the monsters
the other is a race of sentient living
robots from the planet cybertron
so subscribe to be a part of the mind q
family
and now let's get down with this
sickness let's start with the
transformers
they are a species of sentient living
robotic beings mostly originating from
the distant machine world of cybertron
the stories of their lives their
histories and most especially
their wars have been critical across
many different continuities in the mass
multiverse
there are two main factions of
transformers the autobots and the
decepticons and even though they
have different philosophies on how to
run their planet they still have the
same basic designs
which are more crude in form as compared
to the earlier cartoons and movies
as we are discussing michael-based
transformers most of them
are in the range between 20 to 40 feet
tall with some like the driller being
1080 feet long
and the dynobots which are way bigger
and even dragon storm
which are way bigger than normal ones in
earlier continuities and movies the
transformers have had better armor than
planet earth's inhabitants and their
design also seemed to look more
streamlined
since human manufactured weapons such as
bullets and rockets never affected them
in the slightest
whereas in the michael-based movies they
can be damaged easily by human weaponry
the weapons they also use in the film
are usually weapons that can fire more
conventional types of ammunition
such as bigger bullets bigger rockets
and more recently what may be
a shotgun equivalent while in every
other appearances the transformers have
primarily used
either melee weapons such as axes
morning stars and
swords are weapons that can fire lasers
and other forms of condensed energy
projectiles now let's go to the other
corner
mechagodzilla from the most of us was a
mechanized guide you created by apex
cybernetics in order to exterminate
every other titan in the world
so that humans would remain as the
dominant species on earth again
however it would later fall under the
influence of ghidorah and instead sought
out to destroy humanity
instead of saving it like
mechagodzilla's previous incarnations it
is a mecca
that bears a strong resemblance to its
namesake godzilla
except it is considerably more thinner
than previous incarnations of the
character
it is also more skeletal in design and
has huge hands that can be clenched to
grab
and punch mechagodzilla is primarily a
gunmetal silver color
with small hints of black and various
red highlights throughout its body
it supports three rows of dorsal plates
square shaped
and with red lights at each tip that
travels from the head to its back
and converges into one row that travel
down the tail
this mecha is also bigger than godzilla
at maybe 450 feet tall
with a wide range of weapons like the
tail with a drill that can pierce even
the tough height of godzilla himself
it also has a couple of large hands that
are supercharged with plasma
that can throw punches that can even
stun the king of the monsters
the most powerful weapon however is the
proton scream
a beam that can be shot from the mecca's
mouth and can cut through almost
anything inside even
overpowering the mighty atomic breath in
a duel so yes this mecca brings a whole
new level of weapons and powers
if it was ever to enter the transformers
universe and so we will ask this
question now
what would happen if it ever does so
let's play this scenario
mecha godzilla in fact won the fight
against gorman godzilla in hong kong
and there was no way humanity could beat
it and also no other titan was able to
challenge it
and instead they somehow created a
portal and the mecca was sucked into it
the portal was then a connection into
another earth in another universe
mechagodzilla then came out of it and
right in the middle of the events of
transformers the last knight
while the transformers and humans were
in an all-out war cybertron had appeared
just above the earth and ready to
integrate both worlds causing an
apocalypse
of unimaginable scale then mechagodzilla
just appears out of nowhere and starts
battling the transformers humans and all
both autobots and decepticons are taken
aback
with a sudden turn of events the bulk of
the forces of the transformers
and humans are then turned to shoot down
a giant robot
now since the weapons of the
transformers are mainly the same
as basic conventional weaponry of humans
but on a bigger caliber
they are pretty impressive with longer
range and more explosive power
in the range of the firepower of tanks
and fighter jets
but we have also seen tanks and fighter
jets fire volley after volley of shells
and missiles on godzilla
to no effect at all so it's the same for
the mecca
the weapons of the transformers would
have little to no effect on it
instead it just fuels the rage of
ghidorah in the mecca
and it fires its shoulder-based missiles
hitting quite a few of the transformers
destroying a few
and damaging others then it charges up
the proton scream
and fires the beam again and again just
tearing apart the rest of the sentient
robot fighters
well a few of them are left those who
managed to hide out
and get out of the way but at the same
time cybertron was still heading towards
planet earth and with it was quintessa
after finally possessing the staff which
was an artifact of immense power that it
could drain planets of this
life force in order to feed cybertron
the staff also possesses a myriad of
other abilities giving the user
the ability to wield advanced signs
beyond the comprehension of
primitive beings like us humans so it
was decided that this weapon
was to be used against the rampaging
mechagodzilla that was firing beam after
beam of brought on scream onto the
segments of cybertron
that touched down on two planet earth
destroying them
and at the same time it was destroying
unicron's horns as well
which was in this franchise planet earth
itself
then a strange truce was then formed by
the remaining transformers which were
the autobots transformers and even
humans
and they would have to work together to
get rid of the mecca before fighting
each other again
and deciding who would win and so from
here it could
either go two ways there would be two
scenarios the first scenario the
transformers somehow manages to get
a lot of themselves killed but one of
them or maybe two
gets to stick the stuff where the sun
doesn't shine in mechagodzilla
and therefore draining its life force to
replenish cybertron
then there's the other scenario where
mechagodzilla
gets to destroy each and every one of
them and thereby slowly reigning over
two planets at the same time
cybertron and earth but that's not for
me to decide
it's up to you guys and put it down in
the comment section below
and with that we come to the end of this
video so do like for support and
subscribe to be a part of the minecube
family
and be sure to hit that bell button for
regular updates on master videos
right here on mind cue till the next one
take care fam